il est considéré comme l'un des mets les
plus raffinés du monde prisé par les
tsars de russie et les rois le caviar
est toujours synonyme de luxe
après des siècles de surpêche
l'esturgeon qui donne les oeufs de
caviar provient presque exclusivement
des élevages et c'est au coeur de la
sologne que l'on produit aujourd'hui
l'un des meilleurs quarts
[Musique]
dans la famille de vincent ncaa on et
pisciculteurs de père en fils depuis le
16e siècle
mais dans les étangs qu'il gère avec sa
soeur patricia pas de carpes ni de
brochets chaque semaine entre septembre
et mai on pêche l'esturgeon le nombre de
poissons est connu dans le matin et donc
là la notion de bonne pêche elle
intervient plus les mois de septembre
octobre quand on fait la sélection pour
trouver les fenêtres qui sont matures ce
que d'une année sur l'autre on n'a pas
forcément les mêmes pourcentages
donc là on a des petites surprises il ya
quand même du suspense sais pas comment
ils ont grossi le nombre de femelles qui
seront matures à chaque bassin on a une
petite une petite fierté en sologne
ces poissons préhistoriques vivent dans
des conditions proches de leur biotope
naturel avec une concentration dix fois
inférieur aux autres élevages
on a des poissons qui nagent qui
consomment aussi de la nourriture
naturelle si se recréent un écosystème 1
sans débat sans en terre peut charger et
on ajoute des poissons d'ailleurs pour
équilibrer le milieu donc il serait tout
un système de poissons fruits soeur
c'est l'esturgeon des petits poissons
plantes au naufrage des carnassiers et
donc cesser une vie différente pour le
poisson et on en a le le résultat à la
fin on a un produit qui est différent
dans le grand filet de nylon les
esturgeons sont plutôt calmes
ce sont des berry l'une des 27 espèces
recensées là on touche le filet en
priant de complètement les poissons et
là on va pouvoir comme entre électro et
les poissons qui sont rigides donc
n'est ce pas des poubelles on les prend
la main
vincent pratiquer une échographie sur
chaque femelle pour évaluer la taille
des oeufs
donc là c'est la maturité du poisson là
on voit bien les yeux des autres gros
diamètre c'est bon
retour à la ferme piscicole où les
femelles esturgeons resteront près de
trois semaines en bassin
alors ici
passe plus grand chose en fait
localement très peu et de son angle au
clair c'est certes il assigne alors
qu'en fait ils vont passer tout seul 1%
soit turquie et paquebots paradis rodier
du milieu d'élevage
ils viennent donc gatineau du canadien
[Musique]
80% de la production de caviar de
sologne arrive ici dans les laboratoires
de la maison nordique à gennevilliers
chaque boîte est scrutée et goûter par
simone une experte depuis 30 ans j'ai
connu la belle époque du caviar iranien
avec toutes ces différences de couleurs
toutes ses variantes au niveau de la
saveur et quand nous avons découvert le
caviar de sologne
j'avais eu une mauvaise expérience sur
du caviar d'élevage et je me suis dit
c'est un énième caviar d'élevage avec
tout le côté péjoratif que j'avais en
mémoire
et lorsqu'on a goûté ce caviar on s'est
regardé et on s'est dit mais ça nous
rappelle les belles années du caviar
iranien celui ci au niveau de la couleur
bas serait vraiment parfait pour pour le
bristol
monsieur eric fréchon adore le caviar
quand il est très clair maintenant il me
reste à déguster pour savoir si la
couleur est en raccord avec la saveur
c'est absolument fabuleux il éclate
complètement en bouche est toujours
cette saveur de noix noisettes qui
apparaît bien que ce soit un caviar qui
soit extrêmement frais il a déjà toutes
ces caractéristiques de base ce caviar
est réservé aux plus grands chefs
étoilés d'autres boîtes partiront vers
l'asie et les états unis et pour la
boutique restaurant de la maison
nordique apparaît
un écrin de luxe pour ce produit
exceptionnel qui nécessite une bonne
pédagogie particulièrement sur le mode
de conservation
ce qu'il faut retenir essentiellement
sec une boîte de caviar conditionnait
s'ils restent longtemps dans le frigo
malheureusement plus ça vieillit sa
ligne très très mal et c'est pas le but
donc non à travers le procès des dons de
la production à la mise en vente
on réduit tout ça et on offre une une
possibilité à ses clients d'avoir une
autre expérience 1 mais qui reste cher
selon la variété d'esturgeons le caviar
de sologne coûte ici entre 2000 et 2008
100 euros le kilo
bon bon bon compte
retour à saint viâtre au coeur de la
sologne dans l'élevage d'esturgeons de
la famille hennequart près de 20% de la
production est vendue en direct aux
particuliers et à quelques épiceries
locales comme la vinitech à orléans
oui très rapidement des personnes qui
sont venues spontanément et donc même
éloigné tout comme ici on se dit que
c'était une très bonne idée
voilà et puis en fait les clients et d'y
avoir ou le caviar est produit à mort en
contact direct 8 est rentré facture
frédéric et dominique sec
les propriétaires de cette épicerie fine
au pris l'habitude de faire
régulièrement le trajet jusqu'à la
pisciculture solognote beaucoup de gens
quand tu vois qu'à vert de sun et se
lisent mais c'est quoi comme caviar et
il n'imagine pas que ce soit puis c'est
du caviar d'esturgeon pour eux à saint
viâtre en sologne
ils sont surpris ils sont vraiment
surpris raconte l histoire du caviar aux
clients une recette qui marche aussi en
province
ça fonctionne très bien et on se rend
compte tous les ans tout doucement ça
prend ça france
il en espère en fin d'année
matamore
[Musique]
introduire l'esturgeon en sologne était
un pari fou il y a dix ans
la production est passée d'une centaine
de kilos par an après 2,3 tonnes
aujourd'hui
nous en sologne enfin quand on est parti
de l'esturgeon sibérien qui paraissait
finalement assez adaptée en termes de
climat et puis de même de biotope en
général c'est ce qui s'est révélé vrai
quoi on a une similitude en fait avec la
région d'où il vient à la sibérie pas
bien sûr on n'a pas un climat aussi
prononcé mais il ya des écarts de
température qui sont à peu près
identiques à ce qu'on a
et puis c'est un poisson qui vivent dans
des rivières assez sablonneuse avec des
landes au tour donc mon y avait pas d
n'ya pas le deuil avait pas de raison
avec le recul que ça ne fonctionnera
et
après avoir été assommé les poissons
dont les eaux sont arrivés à maturité
sont transférés à l'atelier de
production
c'est là que se fait le prélèvement des
rogues le nom des poches qui entoure les
oeufs d'esturgeons et la qualité
s'apprécie au premier coup d'oeil
déjà rien que l'aspect du poisson peut
nous dire c'est plutôt une belle femelle
et ensuite dès qu'on double dès qu'on
aperçoit donc les oeufs on voit que là
comme l'a par exemple c'est c'est très
beau produire
le poisson sera transformée dans une
usine du berry les hommes quant à eux
vont subir quelques opérations pour
devenir du caviar et si on se retrouve
dans une atmosphère à 4 degrés avec de
l'herbe sous pression de manière à ce
qu'on ait aucune contamination possible
la première étape consiste à passer sur
le tamis laroque
donc il faut égrainé les deux lancements
sur le tamis de façon à part les animer
et à séparer tous les petits tissu qui
les entoure après on récupère donc les
eaux pures c'est ce que vous voyez sur
les petits paniers là bas qu'ils sont
entrain de ces goûters pour ajouter donc
le sel et de manière à cette fois-là
passer à la réalisation du caviar tant
qu'on n'a pas le talent et on est encore
dans l'oeuf mais là on passe au caviar
entre le moment où la femelle est abattu
et le moment où son caviar et est mis
dans une boîte qui se passe à peu près
45 minutes et il faut attendre entre
sept et huit ans pour récolter les oeufs
la joue chaque poisson donnera en
moyenne un kilo et demi de caviar sur
caviar camille dans ces grosses boîtes
bleues
quarante huit heures après on peut à
nouveau y remette dedans des plus grands
mangent plus petits ou le laissait
mature et un temps qui peut aller
jusqu'à plusieurs mois peut le faire
bien révolue donc on est resté vierge
jeunes qui est beurré nous assister au
départ était ensuite tout en
vieillissant ils deviennent un peu plus
fort un peu plus aller plus haut d en
quelques années le caviar de sologne
s'est imposé comme l'un des meilleurs
avec le concours des plus grandes toques
les grands chefs c'est important parce
que c'est là la reconnaissance de gens
dont on peut pas mettre en doute la
qualité de leur goût et la long
quand des gens comme ça bouffon des
compliments pour qu'on peut pas rêver
mieux
des produits locaux d'exception c'est ce
que recherche christophe tu es le
talentueux chef de la maison d'à côté
près de chambord le caviar de sologne
mise en valeur dans cette recette avec
radis et mousse de fans
[Musique]
donc là voilà on a on a ce ce caviar
avec cette toute petite préparation sur
sur leur a dit l'idée c'est c'est pas
dénaturer le caviar il faut vraiment
qu'on ait cette sensation pour le manger
qu'au fur et à mesure on vient le
chercher la fraîcheur du radis un tout
petit peu piquant légèrement et donc
toute la fraîcheur et tout côté onctueux
par rapport à cette crème de fanes de
radis des plats qui ne sont pas à la
portée de toutes les bourses mais le
caviar d'élevage a permis une relative
démocratisation du produit on a plus ou
très peu de caviar sauvage et donc il ya
plus ces tarifs qui atteignaient des
prix entre à l'e3 et 5000 euros
quand même au kilo aujourd'hui nous on a
vraiment réduit complètement ses tarifs
et ce qui nous permet en tous les cas
justement de le faire découvrir et de
permettre
de tout le monde de pouvoir s'en acheter
une petite boîte et le partager
[Musique]
du
le caviar reste un produit de luxe mais
pour vincent et car l'essentiel est
ailleurs dans la fierté d'avoir
pérennisé une entreprise familiale
[Musique]
on est content d'avoir traversé une
phase de reconversion
parce qu'on était une entreprise donc
été surtout orientée sur la polyculture
extensive qui est une activité qui peine
et on a réussi sans sans heurt centraux
qui est de deux drames chez nous donc à
se reconvertir avec bonheur avec le
camion
connu pour ses grands territoires de
chasse la sologne est en train de se
forger une renommée dans le cercle fermé
des amateurs de caviar et abrite
désormais à côté des cervidés et des
sangliers
un autre animal emblématique l'esturgeon